ah
[Música]
las alarmas han vuelto a sonar en kif y
esta vez no ha sido exclusivamente por
la amenaza de nuevos ataques rusos lo
que está sonando en esta ocasión es la
alarma del tesoro nacional porque
querida comunidad el gobierno de ucrania
tiene las arcas prácticamente vacías se
está quedando sin dinero lo que puede
tener no sólo importantes consecuencias
económicas sino también militares esto
que os vamos a contar en este vídeo es
algo así como la otra cara del frente de
guerra una cara indispensable pero que
sin embargo apenas recibe cobertura de
los medios de comunicación ucraniano
solo está luchando contra rusia también
está lidiando con una enorme crisis
económica monetaria y energética cuyas
repercusiones pueden ser enormes pero
hasta qué punto corre ucrania el riesgo
de quebrar cuál es exactamente el daño
que ha provocado la invasión rusa quién
o quiénes están financiando realmente el
esfuerzo de la guerra y quizás la
pregunta más importante de todas que
puede suponer todo esto en el campo de
batalla atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las cosas en el campo de batalla han
mejorado considerablemente para ucrania
seis meses después de comenzar la
invasión los rusos se encuentran
prácticamente estancados ahora su única
ventaja se limita a la práctica a su
poderosa artillería la cual sigue
infligiendo un terrible daño en el
ejército y las ciudades ucranianas la
desproporción entre piezas de artillería
rusas y ucranianas en la primera línea
de combate sigue siendo enorme y aquí la
estrategia de rusia es muy clara
utilizar su enorme músculo artillero
para arrasar con todo a su paso y
facilitar el avance de la infantería sin
embargo pese a ello contra viento y
marea los avances del ejército de putin
se han detenido casi por completo la
atenas resistencia de los ucranianos y
la llegada de armamento occidental le ha
dado al ejército de ucrania mucho más
músculo y eso eso se nota
los ataques ucranianos en crimea
debilitan la capacidad militar de rusia
pero esto corresponde al frente militar
en este vídeo queremos centrar nuestra
atención en otro campo de batalla lo que
podemos llamar el freno y económico
la guerra iniciada por rusia ha tenido
consecuencias devastadoras sobre el
terreno y también sobre la economía
ucraniana muchas fábricas han sido
destruidas las infraestructuras están
siendo muy castigadas y muchas empresas
han tenido que echar el cierre por
ejemplo según varias encuestas la guerra
había militado cerca de la mitad de
todos los empleos del país bien porque
estos han desaparecido bien porque los
salarios y las horas trabajadas se han
desplomado con datos de junio del 2022 y
a pesar de la movilización militar la
tasa de paro superaba ya el 35 por
ciento
fijos por ejemplo en este mapa
durante el verano del 2022 algo más del
20 por ciento de todo el territorio de
ucrania estaba ocupado por rusia o
convertido en un sangriento campo de
batalla estas son las regiones que veis
en azul oscuro pues bien este territorio
suponían antes de la guerra casi el 20
por ciento del pib del país y cerca del
28 por ciento de toda su población
y esto es tan sólo el comienzo porque a
ver evidentemente hay zonas más y menos
afectadas pero rusia ha bombardeado y
atacado infraestructuras fábricas y
ciudades a lo largo y ancho de todo el
país
[Música]
por ejemplo los misiles rusos han
destruido o dañado gravemente todas las
grandes refinerías de petróleo otro
ejemplo algunas de las mayores fábricas
del país se encontraban precisamente en
mariupol y hoy hoy son escombros en
total se calcula que los daños
provocados por rusia tan sólo durante
los seis primeros meses de la guerra se
aproximaron a los 100 mil millones de
dólares una enorme fortuna para uno de
los países más pobres de europa y para
colmo a esa enorme cifra tenemos además
que sumarle decenas y decenas de miles
de millones que se perderán por el
cierre de las fábricas y las empresas y
por todo lo que costará volver a poner
en marcha el país y ni hablemos ya de la
pérdida de vidas o el éxodo masivo de
refugiados el resultado de toda esta
salvaje destrucción pues básicamente el
hundimiento de la moneda ucraniana un
agujero descomunal en las cuentas
públicas una inflación por las nubes la
economía en caída libre
[Música]
de hecho teniendo en cuenta los salarios
ucrania se ha vuelto a convertir en el
país más pobre de toda europa ahora bien
hasta qué punto la crisis amenaza el
futuro de ucrania cuál es exactamente el
nivel de destrucción económica que está
sufriendo el país que puede significar
para la guerra pues bien ahora mismo
vamos a verlo
la guerra
rusia invadida aproximadamente una
quinta parte de ucrania sin embargo de
una forma u otra la guerra afecta al
conjunto del país queréis un ejemplo
concreto pues fijaos según un estudio
realizado a primeros de agosto del 2022
el 54% de los ucranianos tienen seres
queridos familia o amigos luchando
contra el invasor y es que no lo dudéis
la resistencia a rusia se ha convertido
en todo un motivo de orgullo y cuestión
nacional sin embargo las guerras no sólo
son algo doloroso y destructivo también
son terriblemente caras mantener las
operaciones de combate no resulta nada
barato más aún cuando los combates
afectan directamente al tejido económico
del país toman nota según las
autoridades ucranianas el pib se
desplomará más de un 33 por ciento en
2022 una cifra que el banco mundial por
ejemplo eleva hasta un dramático 45% y
el panorama podría ponerse aún peor por
ejemplo prácticamente todos los
proyectos de inversión están parados y
luego los principales bancos de ucrania
se enfrentan a tasas de morosidad
cercanas al 30 por ciento
la situación que si se mantiene en el
tiempo podría ponerlos contra las
cuerdas es decir podrá llevarlos
directamente a la quiebra y claro
evidentemente cuando una economía se
hunde ve tal forma los odiosos públicos
hacen exactamente lo mismo
en ucrania en términos reales durante el
mes de junio la recaudación por
impuestos del gobierno se ha desplomado
casi un 50% respecto al año anterior
pero la guerra hay que financiarla así
que al mismo tiempo que los ingresos se
han reducido a la mitad se calcula que
el gasto público se ha incrementado más
de un 60% el resultado un enorme y
salvaje boquete en las cuentas públicas
y es que veréis a pesar de haber
recortado todo lo no imprescindible en
estos momentos el gobierno ucraniano
apenas está logrando financiar con
impuestos en torno al 30 por ciento de
todo el gasto público hablamos de un
déficit de unos 5 mil millones de
dólares cada mes una cantidad enorme
para un país cuyo pib en 2021 apenas fue
de 200 mil millones de dólares de hecho
si tenemos en cuenta el desplome en la
actividad económica el déficit
proyectado para el 2022 fácilmente
podría llegar a superar el 40 por ciento
del pib y la pregunta es cómo demonios
se puede financiar semejante boquete
presupuestario
pensad que no sólo hablamos de cosas
como las pensiones el salario de los
médicos lo que ya de por sí resulta muy
importante dadas las circunstancias sino
también del propio gasto militar para
poder mantener la guerra ucrania
necesita financiar este gigantesco
déficit la pregunta es cómo hacerlo y
hacer lo que está dispensando obvió
alberto emitiendo deuda como todo el
mundo pues sí pero al mismo tiempo no
piensa lo estaría dispuesto a invertir
tu dinero en comprar deuda de un país al
borde de la quiebra con el 20 por ciento
de su territorio invadido y que además
está en plena guerra con rusia pues
exactamente eso
[Música]
así que además de emitir deuda el
gobierno de zelaya ha tenido que
recurrir a otras medidas por ejemplo el
banco central se ha puesto como loco a
imprimir dinero para financiar al
gobierno el problema es que eso además
de disparar la inflación está
presionando la baja al valor de la
gripe' la divisa ucraniana lo que a su
vez está obligando al banco central a
consumir sus reservas de divisas para
que la moneda local no se desplome del
todo concretamente durante el verano del
2022 el banco central ucraniano ha
estado quemando cada semana un promedio
baja roza la silla de mil millones de
dólares en divisas extranjeras a este
ritmo en pocos meses el país podría
quedarse sin un solo dólar de ahí que
resulta tan importante para ucrania
reabrir las vías comerciales con el
exterior incluida por supuesto la venta
de cereales seguro que habéis oído
hablar de ello en los medios claro que
en el mejor de los casos esta actividad
apenas generaría mil millones de dólares
al mes una cantidad demasiado pequeña
para compensar todas las fugas que tiene
el país y así es como llegamos a
noticias como esta 21 de julio del 2022
ucrania devalúa su moneda la grita 25
por ciento contra el dólar a finales de
julio ucrania decidió devaluar su moneda
un 25 por ciento para intentar
estabilizar su divisa haciendo que las
exportaciones sean más baratas y las
importaciones más caras y así reducir la
salida de dólares del país
pero claro todo esto no son más que
parches ni el banco central puede seguir
financiando masivamente al gobierno ni
el país puede seguir quemando sus
dólares y desde luego los ucranianos son
perfectamente conscientes de ello la
situación es tan delicada que el propio
gobierno le ha pedido a todas las
empresas públicas del país que retrasen
el pago de su deuda e incluso cuando
obtengan dinero para pagarla el objetivo
con ello es frenar la salida de dólares
a cualquier precio y de hecho esto es
algo que ha hecho también el propio
gobierno quien ha acordado con sus
principales acreedores retrasar en un
año todos los pagos de la deuda pública
de ucrania
y por si esto fuera poco aún hay más
otro problema al que se enfrenta este
país es precisamente el invierno ucrania
tiene actualmente el nivel de
almacenamiento de gas más bajo de toda
europa por ejemplo se calcula que a
finales de julio apenas tenía llena el
22% de su capacidad de almacenamiento
una cantidad totalmente insuficiente
para enfrentarse al invierno ucraniano
un invierno condenadamente frío pues
bien los cálculos de la empresa nacional
de gas apuntan a que como mínimo el país
tendrá que comprar 5 mil millones de
metros cúbicos de gas algo que a los
precios actuales del gas en europa puede
tener un coste de más de 10 mil millones
de dólares
y ahí tampoco termina todo ucrania
también tendrá que gastar importantes
recursos para mantener funcionando su
red eléctrica que ha sido muy dañada por
los rusos tanto en lo que respecta a las
centrales como a los propios cables o
las centrales de transformación lo que
por supuesto engordar aún mucho más la
factura pero es que claro un país simple
y llanamente no puede funcionar sin
energía
amigos amigas lo miremos por donde lo
miremos la situación económica en
ucrania es crítica incluso aunque
algunas cosas hayan mejorado respecto a
los momentos iniciales de la invasión si
la mayoría de las empresas del país han
reabierto sus puertas la oferta de
gasolina de diésel y de otros
combustibles se está restableciendo
gracias a que más de 300 camiones
cisterna cruzan cada día la frontera
desde europa el país también le ha
comenzado a vender electricidad a la
unión europea la supresión de aranceles
y de exigencias reglamentarias varias
por parte de los países aliados está
contribuyendo a reactivar las
exportaciones y además la resistencia
del ejército ha hecho que el grueso de
las cosechas pudieran llevarse a cabo
pero a pesar de todo ello el desplome
del pib el cierre de las grandes
fábricas el creciente déficit comercial
y sobre todo el gigantesco boquete en
las cuentas públicas hacen que la
situación sea crítica así que entonces
tenemos que regresar a la pregunta clave
que nos hacíamos antes como demonios
espero planea pagar todas las facturas
pues sabéis que justo aquí es donde
entran en juego los aliados occidentales
atento
la supervivencia de ucrania
hasta ahora el gobierno ucraniano ha
tomado un montón de medidas contrarreloj
para intentar estabilizar la situación
por ejemplo introdujo severos controles
de capitales intervino el tipo de cambio
metió la tijera a un montón de gastos
garantizó los depósitos bancarios
eliminó y cambió algunos impuestos se
elevaron los tipos de interés y así un
largo etcétera etcétera sin embargo tal
y como hemos visto la situación es tan
complicada que por sí misma ucrania
tiene poco que hacer así que justo aquí
es donde entra en juego la comunidad
internacional queridos amigos a eeuu
alan europea al reino unido- y al resto
de aliados no les basta con entregar
equipos militares a ucrania si quieren
que este país tenga éxito en su feroz
resistencia contra rusia también tienen
que ocuparse de la otra cara de la
guerra y sabéis que eso es exactamente
al menos por ahora lo que están haciendo
fijaos en este gráfico aproximadamente
el gobierno de ucrania cubre algo menos
de un tercio de todo su gasto público
con impuestos un importe similar lo
consigue recurriendo al banco central y
luego los aliados ponen el resto una
ayuda a esta que se ha convertido ya con
muchas en la principal fuente de
financiación del déficit público una
ayuda que además se espera que se
incremente durante los próximos meses
para que pueda dejar de imprimir dinero
en total entre el día 24 de febrero del
2022 que fue el día que comenzó la
invasión y comienzos del mes de agosto
el gobierno de ucrania recibió más de
12.000 millones de dólares de eeuu la
unión europea alemania japón canadá y
otros países aliados 12 mil millones en
forma de subvenciones donaciones y
préstamos en condiciones muy pero que
muy ventajosas destinados íntegramente a
financiar el gasto público del gobierno
de excelencia
[Música]
y no sólo eso estos mismos aliados se
han comprometido a desembolsar otros 20
mil millones durante los próximos meses
tan solo para apoyar las finanzas del
gobierno y ojo porque si a esta cantidad
le añadimos la ayuda humanitaria y la
ayuda militar la cifra total que hasta
ahora los aliados se han comprometido a
desembolsar supera los 80 mil millones
de dólares
como podéis ver en este gráfico la mayor
cantidad con mucha diferencia
corresponde a los eeuu esto es mucho
muchísimo dinero hablamos de una
histórica movilización de recursos para
intentar conseguir que el agresor en
este caso rusia lo pague con gracias en
el campo de batalla al fin y al cabo no
sólo se trata de ucrania en esta guerra
está en juego la capacidad de los países
libres para defenderse del chantaje de
una tiranía como la de vladimir putin la
lucha de ucrania es nuestra lucha morten
boskov ministro de defensa de dinamarca
sin embargo lo siento pero tampoco esto
resulta suficiente
la guerra en ucrania no parece que se
vaya a terminar en el corto plazo si las
democracias occidentales realmente
quieren que ucrania consiga defenderse
de la agresión de las huestes de putin
tienen que hacer un esfuerzo mucho mayor
tienen que comprometer más recursos
tanto militares como técnicos y
financieros y sobre todo tienen que
agilizar los desembolsos es decir tienen
que soltar más rápido la pasta y tienen
que hacerlo con la garantía de que el
dinero llegue a donde tiene que llegar
ya os hemos contado que ucrania nunca se
ha caracterizado por tener un estado
derecho de primera o por ser el país más
transparente del mundo pero de una forma
u otra el dinero tiene que llegar tiene
que llegar más rápido entonces las cosas
porque la situación económica de ucrania
es absolutamente crítica y es que esta
es amigos la otra cara de la guerra el
otro frente de batalla en el que se está
trabajando a destajo aunque a la vez
salga por la televisión claro que
titulares como éste parecen indicar otra
cosa las potencias de europa no le
dieron a ucrania nuevas promesas
militares en julio según muestran los
datos el apoyo militar de europa ucrania
ha ido disminuyendo desde abril según
datos del instituto quien a ver el
compromiso de los eeuu el reino unido y
la mayoría de países del este de europa
parece firme sin embargo no está claro
que se pueda decir lo mismo de países
como francia o alemania
[Música]
la crisis energética está comenzando a
castigarlos y la sensación que existe es
que estos países estarían encantados con
la firma de un alto el fuego aunque solo
sea para seguir recibiendo gas de rusia
mientras encuentran alternativas sin
embargo eso podría ser un gran error la
propia casa blanca lo tiene muy claro en
esta guerra está en juego mucho más que
la soberanía ucraniana sobre el donbass
o el sur del país está en juego sobre
todo la supremacía del mundo libre y
también está en juego lo que otros
dictadores como siguen pin pueden
aprender sobre lo que nunca deben hacer
por ejemplo en taiwán además rusia ha
ocupado o mantiene bajo asedio no sólo
muchas de las principales zonas
industriales sino también una parte muy
importante de los recursos naturales del
país lo que podría dificultar y mucho la
reconstrucción de ucrania
algunas estimaciones apuntan a que rusia
se había hecho con más del 60% de los
depósitos de carbón del país con el 42
por ciento de los yacimientos de metales
y con una tercera parte de todos los
depósitos de tierras raras y otros
minerales críticos como el litio y todo
eso por no pensar cuál sería realmente
el futuro de ucrania si rusia no es
claramente derrotada ucrania no sólo
habrá perdido gran parte de su
territorio y de sus recursos sino que
sería constantemente vulnerable a otro
ataque de rusia nadie en su sano juicio
o una empresa privada invertiría en el
resto de ucrania si esto se convirtiera
en un conflicto congelado ya coki
kickoff miembro del institut pearson de
economía y ojo porque hasta ahora sólo
hemos hablado de lo que ucrania necesita
para seguir en pie luchando contra los
rusos pero lo cierto es que a medio y
largo plazo el país necesitará mucho
muchísimo más dinero hablamos según las
estimaciones existentes de cientos y
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
para volver a poner en pie la economía
la industria las ciudades y las
infraestructuras ucranianas la guerra
está siendo devastadora eso sí todo esto
puede parecernos mucho y haber
ciertamente lo ves sin embargo tenemos
que tener en cuenta que el pp acumulado
de los países aliados superan los 50
billones de dólares es decir que tienen
músculo más que suficiente para hacer
frente a toda la factura así que no se
visto de esta forma el precio pagado a
cambio de derrotar a putin y demostrarle
al mundo que conviene ser aliados de los
países libres parece bastante asumible
en cualquier caso esto ya es algo
interpretar
[Música]
lo que está claro es que la guerra en
ucrania va mucho más allá de ucrania
este país es dependiente militar y
financieramente de occidente y se ha
conseguido frenar a la maquinaria de
guerra rusa se debe sobre todo a su pena
de resistencia pero también al
compromiso demostrado por sus aliados
occidentales pero aún así la situación
es crítica hace falta más dinero y hace
falta ya si esto no se produce en la
economía ucraniana podía irse a pique
por completo lo que haría prácticamente
imposible mantener las operaciones de
combate sin producción sin dinero sin
suministros y con una crisis galopante
poco podrían hacer y desde luego si
queréis nuestra opinión aquí en visual
político lo tenemos muy claro hay que
apoyar a ucrania cueste lo que cueste
este es uno de esos momentos históricos
que el mundo libre tiene que imponerse a
las tiranías pero digamos hasta aquí
turno para ti hasta qué punto crees que
los aliados financiarán el esfuerzo de
guerra de ucrania hasta dónde llega su
compromiso es que veremos pronto un alto
el fuego déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios ya sabéis si este vídeo os
resulta interesante no olvidéis darle al
botón de like suscribiros abisal
político si es como no debéis hecho
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]